team biden becomes more and more
disconnected from the realities of
everyday americans and major blue cities
start to push vaccines on children i'm
bench bro this is the bench bureau show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let big tech track what you do
anonymize your web browsing at
expressvpn.com
then we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first here is your reminder
you don't have to wait till black friday
to start saving a lot of money in the
here and now what's one great way to
save money i mean not just right now but
like every month for the rest of time
switch your cell phone coverage from one
of those big guys to pure talk because
you can cut your cell phone bill in half
just by making that switch pure talk
gives you killer 5g coverage on one of
the largest 5g networks in the country
and still saves the average family over
800 a year i made the switch myself the
coverage is excellent their us-based
customer service actually does care
about you and pure tax prices they're
pretty much wholesale they're gonna save
a lot of money you know unlimited talk
text and six gigs of data for just 30
bucks a month and they have options for
unlimited data as well keep your number
keep your phone or this month get black
friday prices on new phones like the
iphone 12 which is 479 dollars which is
a heck of a deal because that thing
retails for over a thousand bucks they
have a 30-day risk-free guarantee so you
literally have nothing to lose go to
puretalk.com shop for a plan and phone
that's right for you then enter promo
code shapiro you will save 50 off your
first month and save on a new phone that
is puretalk.com promo code shapiro
puretalk is simply smarter wireless some
restrictions apply see site for details
alrighty so i'm going to begin today
with a really fascinating report this is
from pew research center and it's
looking at the ways that the american
population breaks down politically and
unlike the sort of typical report where
you have red blue and then independent
this one tries to break down americans
into political typology and so they
break down americans into essentially
nine categories four on the right or
leaning right four on the left or
leaning left and then you have what they
call the stressed sideliners and this
study demonstrates pretty clearly how
the democratic shift to the left is
leaving behind a lot of people and it
explains why exactly the republican
party is in good shape for 2022. so
according to pew
there are two very different groups of
liberal democrats progressive left and
establishment liberals progressive left
the only majority white non-hispanic
group of democrats have very liberal
views on virtually every issue they
support far-reaching changes to address
racial injustice and expand the social
safety net establishment liberals while
just as liberal in many ways as the
progressive left are far less persuaded
of the need for sweeping change there
are two other democratic aligned groups
they couldn't be more different from
each other both demographically and in
their relationship to the democratic
party you got the democratic mainstays
that is the largest democratic oriented
group as well as the oldest on average
these are unshakable democratic
loyalists and have a moderate tilt on
some issues and then you have the
outsider left the youngest typology
group they voted overwhelmingly for
biden a year ago they're liberal in a
lot of their views but they are deeply
frustrated with the political system
including the democratic party and its
leaders then you have four republican
oriented groups so you have three groups
of conservatives the faith and flag
conservatives who are intensely
conservatives intensely conservative
across the board far more likely than
all other typology groups to say
government policies should support
religious values and compromise in
politics is selling out what you believe
in you've got committed conservatives
who express conservative views across
the board they're a little bit softer on
immigration and america's place in the
world and then you have the populist
right who are slightly less educated in
terms of number of degrees they're the
most likely to live in rural areas
they're highly critical of immigrants
and major us corporations this would be
kind of the trumpy wing of the
republican party then you have the
ambivalent right this is the youngest
and least conservative gop aligned group
they're conservative about the size of
government they're economically
conservative but they are they are
fairly liberal when it comes to drugs
for example or abortion and social
issues
they don't like trump very much they uh
a majority voted for him in 2020 but a
lot of them are not big on trump okay
then you have these stressed sideliners
okay the stressed sideliners
is the group with the lowest level of
political engagement they make up 15 of
the public they constituted just 10
percent of voters in 2020 they have a
mix of conservative and liberal views
but they are largely defined by their
minimal interest in politics okay now
the way that these numbers break down in
the american population is that the
faith and flag conservatives are about
ten percent of the population committed
conservatives are about seven percent of
the population that'd be sort of the old
reagan conservatives the populist right
is 11 percent of the population and the
ambivalent right the people who are sort
of younger and less politically engaged
they're about 12 percent of the american
population so overall on the right
you've got about 40 of the american
population then you have the stressed
sideliners or about 15 of the american
population so you got 40 rs and 15
stressed sideliners who break down
fairly evenly by party and then you have
the democratic coalition which
represents about 45
of the american population
okay so what does this mean it means
that much of america's political battle
is over those stressed sideliners
and if democrats continue to skew to the
left to the progressive left
particularly they're in a lot of trouble
so if you are to to create sort of a
political spectrum from right to left on
the far right here you have the faith
and flag conservatives and then on the
far left you have the progressive left
faith and flag conservatives are a lot
closer in orientation to the stressed
sideliners than the progressive left are
the progressive left stress people out
they stress them out in a very very
serious way and they are six percent of
the american population they are the
lowest percent of any political typology
but they are also the most engaged
element of the democratic left
they have enormous control over the
direction in which the democratic left
moves right now
and and particularly they are outspoken
about not just environmental issues but
particularly on racial issues the woke
crowd the progressive left world crowd
which is driving the bus in the
democratic party right now
they are not in line with the vast
majority of americans on a lot of these
issues according to pew perhaps no issue
is more divisive than racial injustice
in the united states among the four
republican oriented typology groups no
more than about a quarter say a lot more
needs to be done to ensure equal rights
for all americans regardless of racial
or ethnic background by comparison no
fewer than three quarters of any
democratic group say a lot more needs to
be done to achieve this goal however
democrats differ over whether the
changes to ensure equal rights for all
can be achieved by working within the
system or whether most laws and
institutions need to be completely
rebuilt
progressive left and outside or left are
far more likely than the other two
democratic groups to say systemic change
is needed to combat racial bias okay so
this has always been a battle inside the
democratic party the battle between the
revolutionaries and between the people
who say that we need to give the
government lots of power so the
government can restructure america from
the inside and barack obama sort of
bridged that gap in 2008 2012 but now
that gap has emerged again and the
progressive left seems to be in charge
on the right a lot of the divisions are
actually economic in nature believe it
or not so republicans tend to be very
much in favor of limited government but
the populist right diverges sharply from
traditional gop positions with their
negative view of corporations only 17
say most corporations make a fair profit
which means that you have sort of a
horseshoe theory republican party in the
progressive right
you know what does this mean it means
that there's not a lot of middle in
american politics if there is a cohesive
middle in american politics it is just
about who pisses them off more it really
is not about there being a lot of shared
values in the middle of the american
spectrum
pew says that there is obviously broad
support for a third major political
party but that is not going to
materialize because the middle is not
one group of people
those stressed sideliners they disagree
on a lot of issues
the stressed sideliners the outsider
left an ambivalent right who are the
closest to the middle of the political
spectrum here
quote have very little in common
politically stressed sideliners hold
mixed views ambivalent right are
conservative on many economic issues
while moderate on some social issues
outside or left are very liberal on most
issues especially on race and the social
safety net what these groups do have in
common is relatively low interest in
politics they had the lowest rates of
voting in the 2020 presidential election
and are less likely than other groups to
follow government and public affairs
most of the time
okay so this leads both parties to have
to make a decision
the decision is do we cater to the
people who are the most engaged so for
the right that would be the faith and
flag conservatives who represent about a
quarter of the base
and on the left that would be the
progressive coalition which only
represents about 12 percent of the
democratic coalition
or do we aim for those stressed
sideliners
now the good news for the republican
party is that with the democrats in
power catering to the far left
you can cater to both the base and the
stressed sideliners
because the stressed sideliners are just
ping-ponging back and forth based on who
stresses them out as the name would sort
of suggest
they're not motivated to get up off
their butts and vote in favor of an
agenda but they may be motivated to get
up and vote
by something that they really really
really dislike they didn't show up a lot
in 2020 if they did show up they voted
overwhelmingly for biden because trump
stressed them out
now if they get up and they vote
presumably they're not going to vote for
joe biden
so the democratic coalition is
essentially being run at this point
by the segment that is the smallest in
their coalition but also the most
politically engaged
and that is
pretty scary if you're a democratic if
you're a democratic strategist if you're
james carville you got to be freaking
out right now because the political
engagement among typology groups shows
that faith and flag conservatives who
represent about 23 of the republican
population and 10 of the american
population overall are the most engaged
republicans committed conservatives and
populist right are also pretty engaged
however the most engaged by far on the
left are the progressive left by far and
they represent a tiny
constituency inside the general american
population
that is it that is a serious problem for
the democratic party
and
then you look to how political typology
groups view major issues and you can see
that the progressive left is
really out of touch with the stressed
sideliners with the people who are
closer to the middle
they're just
they're extremely
far to the left is the bottom line
especially when you get to racial issues
on economic issues they're not as
disconnected from everybody else's as
you might think
but when it comes to social issues they
are way the hell out there
like really really far out there so for
example
look at the stats right now on the
question of who does a lot more need to
be done to ensure equal rights for all
americans regardless of their racial or
ethnic background so virtually everybody
on the right says that's not a major
issue
the people who are the stressed
sideliners about 50 say yes 50 say no
nearly 100 of the progressive left says
that a lot more needs to be done
a 75 percent of the progressive left
says that they have strong support for
black lives matter the movement
hey the rest of the democratic party is
averaging about 50 and the stress
sideliners are down there at about 13
if you look at the question of whether
there is a lot of discrimination against
black people in society 80
of the progressive left says yes and
that is mirrored they're dragging the
party to the left that is mirrored by
establishment liberals democratic
mainstays and even the outsider left but
the stressed sideliners are down at
about 40
on the question of whether there's a lot
of discrimination against black people
in society
and that that's a again these are
serious disconnects for the democratic
party on the issue of the day the
embrace of of equity politics as the
driving force in democratic politics or
the embrace of radical environmentalism
which you've seen from this
administration i understand why they're
doing it they're attacking that way
because these are the activists but if
you become hostage to the activist class
you have a real serious problem
on your hands
like a very serious fact look at the
progressive left when it comes to belief
in god okay
here's a question in this poll
it is important for a person to believe
in god in order to be considered good
and moral
so
virtually everybody from the center to
the right says yes
okay in terms of like a majority of
every group including stressed
sideliners say yes in fact stress
sideliners are more likely than the
ambivalent right to say it's important
for a person to believe in god
only about 12
of progressives say it's important for a
person to believe in god to be
considered good and moral
unbelievably enough
it looks like about five to ten percent
of progressive leftists say society is
better off if people make marriage and
having children a priority
now what's amazing about that stat and
what is devastating for the future of
the country by the way is that really
only
faith and flag conservatives believe by
broad majorities that society is better
off of people have make
make having marriage and children a
priority
like only it's kind of amazing like even
members of the populist right or the
ambivalent right
are not super sold on marriage and kids
which is really really not a good sign
for the rest of america but
even so
the the
position that god is kind of important
in life
is rejected by broad swaths of the
progressive left but nobody else
nobody else
and so on this is why you wonder why
social issues matter so much to
americans because social issues do
define the future of the country and the
progressive left is driving the bus on
those social issues
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first let's talk about the
greatest underwear on planet earth i'm
talking about tommy john underwood these
things are so good that once i got tommy
john underwear i literally took all my
other underwear and i threw them out
because tommy john underwear are super
comfortable they're breathable they're
lightweight they're moisture wicking
they have four times the stretch of
competing brands you'll feel the same
level of comfort layering their
luxuriously soft loungewear right on top
they have other stuff not just underwear
they are comfortable and good looking
you can and you will be wearing them
anywhere which is why tommy johns
doesn't have customers they have
fanatics with over 96 4 star plus
reviews and over 16 million pairs sold
you have to try a pair for yourself plus
it is all backed by that tommy john best
pair you'll ever wear or it's free
guarantee get 20 off your first order
right now at tommyjohn.com ben that is
tommyjohn.com ben for 20 off
tommyjohn.com see site for details again
i love my tommy john underwear one thing
that matters to me by the way they're
really durable like you can put them
through the wash a bunch of times and
they're the same as when they came out
of the package super lightweight super
breathable very convenient go check them
out right now go check out the tommy
john's men's underwear and all their
other products it really is good stuff
go check them out right now okay so
back to this pew research poll looking
at the political breakdown of the united
states
and it is uh it is sort of fascinating
again how the
how the situation breaks down
not really demographically but but much
more in terms of political belief and
who is closer to the center
now the the far left is not close to the
center at all the far left is actually
pretty damned far left and the faith in
flag conservatives are not nearly as as
far from the center as the progressive
left is
that i think is the key factor here in
why the progressive left is alienating
that center
it's it's quite fascinating and again it
demonstrates i think that being very
online is a disaster for the democratic
party
if they continue to press forward
issues of environmentalism which is not
a major priority
for for so many democrats a lot of
democrats are not are not super sold on
this sort of stuff
right this is what pew says they say in
several key issue areas including
environmental policy gun policy abortion
racial equality and other topics
differences across the coalition are
less about the issue itself than the
than in the intensity of support for
liberal positions and policies
so if you look at
progressive
left versus the rest of the the
democratic party and the breakdown
the most liberal group nearly 80 percent
call themselves liberal including 42 who
describes themselves as very liberal the
progressive left that's only 12 percent
of democrats
but if you look at establishment
liberals
establishment liberals
about half of them consider themselves
moderate or even net conservative
democratic mainstays mostly consider
themselves
moderate
so the progressive left driving the bus
they're alienating many of their many of
their own folks
and the issues that they prioritize are
not the issues prioritized by the rest
of america this is why it is it is an
act of political malpractice frankly
what the biden team is doing what the
democrats are doing by driving everybody
to the left it's political malpractice
they have actually embraced a strategy
that republicans embraced a while ago
and then sort of abandoned which was
what if we just keep doubling down on
the base over and over and over and over
republicans did that in 2018 and it went
very poorly for them they did it again a
little bit in 2020 on the presidential
level and it didn't go great
and then you saw in virginia and new
jersey they didn't do that they
broadened out
not in terms even of their policy but in
terms of their appeal
and suddenly they were winning shocking
victories
the democrats however have decided
they're going to just go as radical as
they possibly can and go hard or go home
and i i don't i honestly do not
understand what is driving it okay so
you can see the disconnect that is now
being driven
again those stressed sideliners are only
going to come out and vote
if their stress becomes too great
and the same thing is true for the the
most politically disengaged groups only
show up to vote when they are angry and
when they're upset they don't show up to
vote because they are deeply entrenched
in the utopian vision of the far left
and yet that's what the democrats are
pushing okay so
team biden has made a big showing at
cop26 if you want to know about the vast
disconnect between the american public
and the democratic party just understand
that every major democratic politician
has now made a priority to go over to
glasgow and speak in front of a bunch of
europeans about climate change which is
not a major priority for nearly any
americans outside of the progressive
left it is just not because it is at
best a problem that is going to affect
people over the course of the next
century and people are very well suited
to adaptation we are very very good at
it but for democrats it's a major issue
why because again it is part of a
broader utopian vision for reshaping
everything from economic systems to
the basic notions of the meritocracy and
so nancy pelosi travels over to glasgow
and she speaks says we are proud of
president biden on climate i don't know
who is seriously who who's proud of
president biden on climate who are these
people
and and are you completely disconnected
from the american public i mean for
nancy pelosi the answer has always been
yes right she was getting her hair cut
while nobody else could get their hair
cut without a mask she was eating gelato
in her
next to her
20 000 sub-zero refrigerator while
talking about how everybody should
should stay home and everything was fine
during the pandemic this lady is in a
state of complete denial about the
nature of reality for a huge swath of
americans here she is doing this again
with regard to climate
led by our delegation the united states
congress is showing the world true
climate leadership we're proud of our
president
he was one of the first people in
congress in 1986 to introduce
legislation to address the climate
crisis he takes great pride in that he's
worked on it ever since and now in the
lead as president of the united states
he knows as we all do this is all about
the children leaving a world where they
can be healthy
more secure and more in reach of their
fulfillment
i have a question who's she appealing to
seriously who is she appealing to
and and really what is her goal i mean
when she's speaking about this stuff
again she's at this climate change
summit for the un which is the most
highly of international politics a hive
of scum and villainy
here she is talking about the
interconnectedness of climate change and
gender justice
when you just speak progressive
buzzwords no one knows what the hell
you're talking about
you're utterly disconnected here she is
this is a nearly trillion dollar
investment in build back better and
bipartisan infrastructure framework
recognizes the interconnectedness of
climate change and gender justice and
enables women and girls to lead a just
transition to a clean energy economy of
the future
okay again gender justice what are you
talking about lady
what what are you even talking about
climate change and gender justice
the the democrats have become a parody
of the old new york times
pseudo headline is that the the old joke
about the new york times that the new
york times is going to run a headline
that said world to end tomorrow women
and minorities hit hardest
that's literally what you say
she's saying climate change is going to
hurt women the most it's only going to
hurt women like what are you talking
about you're literally talking about how
the earth is warming which affects
everyone but it's only apparently going
to affect women
and then you've got the media backing
this sort of stuff when the media this
is part of the problem for the democrats
the media are infused with the spirit of
the progressive left and they just keep
mirroring back to democrats this echo
chamber of the hardcore progressive left
so you end up with an article by maxine
joslow at the washington post gracing
the front page of their website led by
pelosi democrats tried to convince the
world that the us is back on climate
change question how many americans give
a crap
really we got inflation out there people
aren't getting back to work in the
numbers they should be getting back to
work people are worried about whether
localities are going to force their kids
to vaccinate people are worried about
whether they're ever going to be able to
unmask but don't worry nancy pelosi is
busy
attempting to convince the french that
we're serious about climate change who
gives ah crap but the biden crowd does
because the biden crowd have convinced
themselves somehow that their coalition
is unbreakable but that's not true their
coalition is very breakable the only
thing that kept that coalition together
throughout the trump years was trump
himself if it had not been for trump the
democrats would have shattered on the
shoals of everything
the same thing held true by the way when
barack obama was president there was
wide disagreement among democrats about
barack obama's policies
like everything from
obamacare and and whether healthcare
should have a public option
to his tax policies
they were only held together by the fact
that the media declared all republicans
were evil and racist and the tea party
was evil and racist
what happens when the republican party
just is not there for you to bounce off
of what if they're what if trump is not
there for them to kick around anymore
they start to break up they start to
shatter but they've convinced themselves
somehow that this radical agenda is
popular
uh i'm honestly i sort of sit here in
amazement that this is what they got
nancy pelosi over there
maybe climate change we're gonna get
into the ugandans we're serious like
who are you talking to lady who are you
talking to we're gonna get some more of
this in just one second first
let's talk about a simple fact at some
point in the very near future i would
imagine the mortgage rates are going to
go up the reason is that the fed is
tapering monetary policy is going to be
a little bit tighter so if you've been
looking at a mortgage refinance but you
haven't actually done it yet you really
should get in under the wire right now
if you're a homeowner who's focused on
your budget focused on your future focus
on finding the right option to save
money i have something for you to
consider a mortgage refinance it is a
strategic approach that makes sense for
a lot of people because rates remain at
near all-time lows making it a great
time to call american financing learn
about custom loan options that can save
you up to a thousand bucks a month
that's right every month because they do
more than just lower your rate they look
at your entire financial picture finding
every way to help you save no pressure
no obligation no upfront or hidden fees
so why not learn more they will give you
a free mortgage review you might skip
two payments if you choose to move
forward pre-qualify for free by calling
866-721-3300 that is
866-721-3300 or visit
americanfinancing.net again pre-qualify
for free right now call
866-721-30-300-866-7213
six seven two one thirty
hundred nmls one eight two three three
four and mls consumer access dot org
alrighty so
it's not just nancy pelosi joe biden
keeps nominating people to positions of
power who are incredibly radical on the
hard left so for example he has
nominated a person named saul omarova
whose background is literally that she
did a fellowship in moscow while the
soviet union was still standing on
economics and the biden administration
refuses to release the papers that she
did while she was studying over in
moscow because it's pretty obvious that
she has a lot of sympathies toward the
red left
here she was not all that long ago
literally saying she's being nominated
to head up
a banking regulatory agency like a
massive part of the banking regulatory
infrastructure she says you know what we
should work on bankrupting the oil coal
and gas industries
um excuse me you mean how most americans
get their power
and where large swaths of americans are
employed
so this is the person you're nominating
joe biden captain moderation over here
all right
nikki mack will be able the nia will be
able to negotiate equity stakes in
private enterprise that receives that
public aid be it a part of the systemic
bailout or be it part of for example
individualized restructuring help for
example for certain
troubled industries and firms that are
in transitioning and here what i'm
thinking about is primarily coal
industry and oil and gas industry a lot
of the smaller players in that industry
are
uh going to probably uh go bankrupt in
in in short order at least we want them
to go bankrupt if we want to tackle
climate change right
we want them to go bankrupt because we
want to tackle climate change
who are these people talking to
you still need the power that powers
your house you still need the gas that
powers your car who are these people
talking to who are they talking to
and they're in congress too right you've
got representative illinois saying
basically the same thing she's now
trying to get fossil fuel producers to
pay 500 billion dollars for past
greenhouse gas emissions there's only
one problem we all used the carbon-based
fossil fuels that produced the
greenhouse gases
and this is not like
philip morris lying about the effects of
smoking
we are all well aware that smog is a
product for example of of using gas in
your car okay we are all well aware of
this sort of stuff we all participated
in it we did beca and we still
participate in it because guess what
most of us are pretty well-founded in
our belief that human beings will adapt
to a variation in the climate over the
course of a hundred years
but here i mean what is this really
about it's about bankrupting these
industries the same thing as solomon
roma omarova
large bipartisan majority of the united
states public believe
that fossil fuel corporations have a
responsibility to address the dire
consequences of their pollution
the largest fossil fuel producers must
pay for their past greenhouse gas
emissions which could raise at least 500
billion alone
they must pay for the lives they have
taken for the futures they have dropped
and for the lasting toll their greed
will have on the planet for generations
to come
i have a question does she really
believe that if there had been no gas
companies oil and gas companies the
world would be anywhere close to as
wealthy as it is right now
carbon-based fossil fuels are one of the
great discoveries in the history of
mankind raising literally billions of
people from abject poverty in countries
where carbon-based fossil fuels are not
available people are still burning dung
for fuel they're still burning dung and
wood for fuel which is actually really
bad for humans and also not great for
the environment by the way
meanwhile you have commerce secretary
gina raimondo again hostage of the
progressive left i
i'm almost at a loss for words for how
stupid it is that the democrats have
decided to move in this direction i
don't know
who is guiding this policy or why why
they refuse to triangulate to the middle
listen i'm i'm a person of the right and
i would much prefer to see the democrats
continue to embrace the suck and then
lose because of it like do it really go
as woke as you want go as radically
environmentalist as you want i'm just
bemused as a political observer and
someone who's done this professionally
for 20 years to watch joe biden the man
who's elected in the teeth of bernie
sanders a man who was elected to
deliberately push back against the
radical left embrace the entire agenda
of the radical left like i don't know
what's i mean the answer maybe is that
there's not a lot knocking around in
that brain these days
and there's uh that is an empty room
with a lot of cobwebs upstairs that
attic is is definitely not full there
are a few ghouls hanging around up there
anyway gina raimondo
who's the commerce secretary
is continuing to push this sort of
nonsense equity is at the center of
everything we do okay so this is the
coded
racial equity language the ibram x candy
language pushed by the radical
progressive left
broadband is the gateway to economic
opportunity and so in order to open that
gateway we're putting equity at the
center of everything we do
i will say
to truly transform our economy into one
that works for all americans and one
that will make our country more
competitive on the world stage
we have to make investments in a way
that is equitable and just
and we view this lens across all of the
work we do at the commerce department
and it will be particularly front and
center with the broadband work that we
will be doing
broadband equity broadband equity hey
meanwhile the biden administration has
now nominated a progressive partisan
named gigi sone to the federal
communications commission this is
according to the wall street journal the
white house last month hail stone is one
of the nation's leading public advocates
for open affordable and democratic
communications networks translation she
favors deploying the agency's regulatory
power to shackle broadband providers and
silence conservative voices
miss sohn founded the left-wing group
public knowledge that has long sought
more government control of the internet
and media she was a counselor to obama
fcc chair tom wheeler and was a driving
force behind net neutrality regulation
that classified broadband providers as
common carriers under title ii of the
communications act of 1934.
the wheeler rule banned broadband
carriers from charging heavy band with
consuming websites like netflix and
facebook more to carry their content
she's also hinted at deploying the
agency's regulatory power to censor
conservative media she tweeted in
october of last year quote for all my
concerns about facebook i believe fox
news has had the most negative impact on
our democracy it is state-sponsored
propaganda with few if any opposing
viewpoints
she has suggested using the fcc power
over broadcast licenses to censor
conservative outlets
after tribune broadcasting abandoned its
merger with sinclair broadcast in 2018
she said today is a good day for every
american who believes that diverse's
avoid diversity of voices in the media
is better for our democracy and urged
the fcc to look at whether sinclair is
qualified to be a broadcast licensee at
all
the fcc is split two too if son is
confirmed democrats will quickly move on
the progressive agenda
i mean it's it's just it's incredible so
they're embracing a hard leftism in
every single form
and they're not hiding the ball about it
either again this is being driven by an
elite progressive left
and the agenda is is not unclear and
jamel bowie makes the agenda
particularly clear today he has a piece
in the new york times called what
structural racism really means and what
he actually concludes is the only way to
fight structural racism is not to fight
racism per se is to dismantle all of the
institutions of society
he says quote racism does not survive in
the main because of personal belief and
prejudice it survives because it is
inscribed and reinscribed by the
relationships and dynamics that
structure our society from segregation
and exclusion to inequality and
degradation of labor
right so capitalism has to go
the meritocracy has to go
jamal bowie writes the solution as the
reverend dr martin luther king jr wrote
in his year in the year of his
assassination must involve a revolution
of values that will look uneasily on the
glaring contrast of poverty and wealth
and see that an edifice which produces
beggars needs restructuring
if democracy is to have meaning king
declared it is necessary to adjust this
inequity it is not only moral but it is
also intelligent we are wasting and
degrading human life by clinging to
archaic thinking by archaic thinking
jamel bowie quoting dr martin luther
king jr there
is means capitalism and free markets
he says there's an inextricable link
between all the things that make your
life good and racism and inequity and
evil
this is the group of people that the
democratic party is now hostage to the
progressive left we'll get some more of
this in just one second because really
it is elite
it is an elite group of people who have
benefited from the system and now are
looking down on the system and spitting
at it because the vast majority of
people who are living in moderate
circumstances in the united states
middle to low income in the united
states are not on board with this crap
we'll get some more of it in one moment
first
i'm thrilled to introduce an incredible
app that everyone who buys gas needs to
know about get upside my listeners are
making up to 25 cents for every gallon
of gas every time they fill up just
download the free get upside app in the
app store or google play right now use
promo code shapiro get a bonus 25 cents
per gallon on your first fill up that's
up to 50 cents cash back don't pay full
price of the pump anymore get cash back
using get upside just download the app
for free use promo code shapiro you can
get up to 50 cents per gallon cashback
on your first tank it comes in
extraordinarily handy these days as the
gas prices are out of control thanks to
the idiocy of the biden administration
at least in part some people who drive a
lot are making as much as two to three
hundred bucks a month in cash back there
is no catch the cash back gets added
directly to your account you can cash
out any time to your bank account paypal
or an e-gift card for amazon and other
brands just download that free get
upside app use promo code shapiro get up
to 50 cents per gallon cashback on your
very first tank of gas that is code
shapiro go to the app store get that get
upside app right now for free and use
promo code shapiro to get up to 50 cents
per gallon cashback on your first tank
of gas plus 25 cents for every gallon of
gas every time you fill up from now on
go check out get upside app okay so
it is a group of elite people who
believe this sort of stuff
and they treat themselves like the elite
and they are bubbled off from the rest
of society it is not a coincidence that
joe biden has spent most of his life
bubbled off from the rest of society it
is not a coincidence that the colonists
of the new york times do not live like
most americans live
it is not a coincidence that nancy
pelosi for goodness sake spends her days
completely
bubbled off and and segregated off from
the rest of normal human society
and they all hang around together and
they'll go to parties together so gavin
newsom went completely missing for like
11 days and there was a lot of
speculation about gavin newsom going
missing for 11 days because it had
happened right after his booster shot
etc okay so gavin newsom recently
revealed where he was apparently
he went to a lux wedding in san
francisco
the wedding of iv getty
according to the san francisco chronicle
the san francisco royalty that is the
getty family took over their hometown
this past week for a grand wedding
reportedly attended by governor gavin
newsom during his extended public
absence that was all sorts of strange
covered in detail by vogue the lux
affair celebrated the nuptials of ivy
getty great granddaughter of oil tycoon
j paul getty and photographer tobias
alexander engel
here's a recap of the weirdest things
that went down from iv drips to famous
bridesmaids
so pelosi presided over this thing
the affair took place at san francisco
city hall it was decorated for the
occasion with pink and teal persian rugs
even the massive rotunda was carpeted
you can see the picture here
see the massive veil you see little
girls dressed up as angels but then you
see nancy pelosi standing there like
elizabeth banks from pan m
presiding over the hunger games
you have ivy getty dressed in what
appears to be
pieces of a mirror that have been glued
to a dress
and um and there's nancy pelosi
presiding all unmasked by the way
according to vogue attendees were asked
to put on masks ahead of pelosi's
appearance but that didn't stop her she
was she was still not wearing her mask
as she presided over all of this
the bridesmaids included people like
anya taylor joy
who's the lead in queen's gambit
she apparently led the bridal party in a
dance down the aisle to miracles can
happen sung by myra
london breed showed up gavin newsom
showed up
the dog there was a dog for a ring
bearer
and after a late night mod party on
friday the wedding party kicked off
saturday morning with a picnic at the
log cabin on the presidio iv drips were
at the ready for anyone in need of help
recovering from the night before
so they brought in the ivy drips
the wedding was themed in honor of ivy
getty's grandmother
apparently it was all about interior
design
even getty's ring included diamonds
given to her by her grandmother when the
bride was a teenager so it was just the
height of luxuriousness meanwhile gavin
newsom is still telling people that
their kids have to be vaccinated and
london breed is not masking while she
informs every kid in san francisco that
if you want to go to a movie you need to
be vaccinated and or mascot
okay these are the elites
we have prince harry out there who's now
testifying that he is talking with jack
dorsey of twitter about how
jack dorsey was allowing a coup to be
staged in early january who gives a crap
what prince harry has to say about all
this but again he's part of the global
elite along with meghan markle
the the greatest most brilliant minds
the people who are most connected with
the needs of everyday americans here's
prince harry
who uh who's now trying to explain to
jack dorsey how american politics ought
to work
have you ever had a chance to present
your case to the leaders of these
companies mark zuckerberg jack dorsey
no not not not directly not personally
um
uh jack and i were
were emailing each other prior to
january the sixth where i warned him
that his platform was
allowing a coup to be staged that email
was sent the day before and then it
happened and i haven't heard from him
since
well prince harry said so and we must
listen to him
prince harry i mean if we don't take
very seriously his warnings about an
american coup after he came directly
from britain where he crapped on his own
grandmother for no reason at all
well then
we'll just we're not fit as americans we
must take his advice for sure as the
scion of a family who is completely
useless in his actual role of being a
useless person he's so useless that he's
useless at being useless he must take
him incredibly seriously prince harry
well i'm so glad he's talking with jack
dorsey about american politics very
important stuff
and meanwhile however question how do
the everyday americans do how y'all
doing out there
are you going to ivy getty's wedding on
mass
are you
traveling in the same circles as nancy
pelosi you're taking a jet into
into scotland to
talk about the the need for climate
justice
are you hanging out with ilhan omar and
and talking about why we need to
bankrupt the oil and gas companies
is that are these high priorities for
you well that's how americans are
actually being faced down with the
predations of this government in one
second first let's talk about the
college education that you are about to
get or that you're going to get for your
kid so let me just put this away a lot
of colleges are a giant waste of time
they don't teach values they don't teach
skills i've been reading your reports
over the last couple of days about how
something like forty percent of people
who enter college drop out and about how
28 of the people who stay in end up
spending more for the degree than the
degree is worth don't be one of those
people instead head on over to grand
canyon university an affordable
christian university one of the largest
fastest growing universities in the
country located in sunny phoenix arizona
gcu is ranked top 20 for best college
campuses in america and offers over 275
engaging academic programs with over 240
online gcu integrates the free market
system with a welcoming christian
worldview perspective into its academic
programs so you can put your faith into
action and help transform communities in
2020 gcu students received over 290
million dollars in scholarships with
many attending gcu for less than the
cost of a state university
find your purpose at gcu private
christian affordable visit gcu.edu my
offer to see what scholarships you
qualify for i recommend it highly i
visited there the student body is great
the campus is fantastic they have
terrific faculty go check them out right
now
gcu.edu
my offer alrighty coming up we'll get to
the actual issues now facing americans
which do not include climate justice
or
environmental gender studies or any of
the rest of the nonsense that the left
is pushing first as most of you know the
daily wire filed a lawsuit against the
feds in order to fight their tyrannical
vaccine mandates within a week of filing
the lawsuit we've seen a big boost to
our case the fifth circuit court of
appeals issued a temporary stay over the
weekend preventing joe biden's mandate
from going into effect citing grave
statutory and constitutional issues
that's big news the fight is not even
close to over it is just getting started
right now we're not just fighting
obviously for our own employees but
we're getting this mandate struck down
for all employees and we want everybody
to have medical freedom and stand up to
the tyrannical mandate baxter or
unbacked everybody's voice should be
heard so if you believe in your medical
freedom and the medical freedom of your
neighbor for that matter and you want to
support the fight against tyranny i hope
you'll take a minute sign our petition
against joe biden's authoritarian
mandate
we have a goal of collecting 500 000
signatures that would send a powerful
message to joe biden and the legacy
media that americans do not comply with
tyranny hundreds of thousands of
americans have already signed the
petition we need a lot more people to
stand with us to reach that goal of half
a million signatures so please head on
over to dailywire.com do not comply and
sign the petition today
now even though we are locked in the
middle of a battle with the feds the
daily wire is not going to let that stop
us from growing our platform we're
launching daily wire now that means
you'll be able to stream all your
favorite daily water shows like this one
on vizio smartcast you can also check
out candace's show or you can check out
matt walsh there's always something
interesting to stream watch daily wire
now exclusively on vizio watch free plus
streaming app on channel 162 to access
the content you love 24 hours a day
seven days a week only on vizio
smartcast
meanwhile our senile leader was elected
to one of the most powerful positions in
the world a year ago and now we are
going to unpack how that first year has
been going and how it is affecting the
american people tune in tonight because
i'm flying into nashville to take part
in the much beloved backstage where we
discuss how americans are fighting back
join me jeremy boring michael knowles
matt walsh and andrew clavin tonight 7
pm eastern 6 pm central on dailywire.com
and on our youtube channel daily wire
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
so how are things going for the everyday
americans who are not members of the pan
am crowd well um u.s inflation reached
30-year high in october according to the
wall street journal
it rose at 6.2 percent annualized as
pandemic related supply shortages and
continued strength and consumer demand
continued to push up prices the labor
department said the consumer price index
which measures what consumers pay for
goods and services increased at the
fastest annual pace since 1990.
inflation also topped five percent for
the fifth straight month
and everybody is starting to notice
including in the mainstream at media
according to cnbc we're now seeing the
largest producer price inflation in
modern history
on final demand year over year uh 8.6
expected 8.6 is what we end up with and
8.6 is the second time in a row and both
of these are the highest ever going back
to the very first month which was
november 2010 when they recalibrated how
they calculate this
okay and meanwhile over on abc news
they're recognizing for example that the
vaccine mandates and the consequent
staffing shortages are going to really
hold things up for the holidays
now to potential holiday travel chaos
the deadline for tsa agents to be fully
vaccinated combined with staffing
shortages at many airlines could spell
disaster for getting to your holiday
destinations the holiday travel crowds
are coming delta says the sunday after
thanksgiving they're expecting 550 000
passengers that is the most of any day
since the start of the pandemic but the
airline industry has already seen
several operational meltdowns this year
and a lot of people are wondering if the
system can handle this coming rush
same network same message abc news says
heating costs are about to slam while
it's in the colder areas of the country
as well
heating costs this winter are expected
to hit our wallets hard and some like
marissa vernon her husband are watching
any hikes closely i am nervous about my
bill
i run a small business out of my house
and i also work full time remote so the
cost of any bill going up is alarming
the vernas say their gas bill is roughly
240 dollars but with projected increases
it could be as high as 360 dollars
and meanwhile cbs news is reporting
supply chain bottlenecks ruining the
holidays supply chain bottlenecks could
ruin americans holiday plants
thanksgiving of course is a time when
many families and friends gather to eat
a big meal complete with turkey with
stuffing pumpkin pie even but grocery
stores are already struggling to fill
empty shelves and people can expect to
pay record high prices for their holiday
food
so all of this is going particularly
well for the bite administration it
turns out the consequences being utterly
disconnected from the american people is
that no one likes you joe biden is
currently riding in the upper 30s he's
going to go lower than that before all
of this is over because he is
disconnected from the american people
and i'm sorry spending 1.2 trillion
half of which is going to go to climate
change related garbage is not
a thing it is not a thing okay most of
the money that he is now spending is not
going to impact how americans live
everybody knows this that bipartisan
infrastructure deal is going to
accomplish pretty much nothing in terms
of how everyday americans live
and just remember only about 200 billion
dollars of that is to be spent on what
we call hard infrastructure here in the
united states
every year the feds state and local
governments spend upwards of 300 billion
dollars on infrastructure
most of the roads you ride on are not in
dire shape most of the bridges you ride
on are not in danger of collapse so this
is just going to go down in history as
another boondoggle another bunch of
money spent for no reason and joe biden
starting to try and realize here
apparently that the american people are
are worried but he's got no solutions
for them other than to continue moving
to the left for some odd reason
we're in a situation where there's a lot
of a lot of anxiety gas prices are up
exceedingly high they've been up this
high before but not
not recently gas prey that's why i have
the attorney general taking a look at
whether or not
these gas companies are gouging
people because although the price of oil
is coming down some the price of gas
hadn't come down some so there's a lot
of things that have people that are
really a great deal of anxiety a great
deal of concern
i wonder why joe i wonder why
i mean first of all this guy won't even
get a physical
and this is a story that broke yesterday
is that he had promised you'd get a
physical and make those results public
by the end of the year um we are
approaching the end of the year no
physical for joe biden he hasn't had a
physical apparently for two years here's
the the white house assistant press
secretary karine jean-pierre explaining
much earlier this year that the
president would be getting his annual
physical later this year it's obviously
later this year the year is almost up so
when will he be getting that physical i
i don't have anything for you as jen has
said and we have said that is going to
happen and once it does we will be
transparent about it
before
that's i think that's what we have said
in the past we will get this done we'll
we'll make sure to get this done and
share it with all of you
yeah we look forward to hearing the
results about our senile president of
the united states meanwhile blue states
blue cities they continue the vaccine
insanity and the lockdowns and all the
rest bill de blasio the communist
groundhog murderer from new york he said
yesterday that new york should seek to
force five-year-olds to show proof of
vaccination to basically go in public
now
at what point will you ask them to also
start checking for vax cards for five to
11 year olds
that's a very good question and honestly
one we need to focus on now we wanted to
get to the day where we actually could
vaccinate youngest new yorkers and get
that rolling we know it'll take a while
i mean right now to use the example of
the 12 to 17 year olds
very good news we're almost at 79
percent of them that's fantastic but it
did take a while
okay so he's gonna force five-year-olds
now to get vaccinated in los angeles
thousands of gyms restaurants movie
theaters shopping mall salons and other
indoor businesses in l.a were acquired
this week to start asking customers for
proof of vaccination under one of the
nation's strictest vaccination rules
this is according to the new york times
the law approved by the city council
last month allows people with medical
conditions that preclude vaccination or
a sincerely held religious objection to
instead show proof of a negative covid
test but the idea is that they are
forcing every business in la to now card
people for vaccines
how are americans enjoying the wild
authoritarian leftism of the biden
administration and their and their local
allies i would say not all that much not
all that much
when you when you disconnect from the
american people the american people tend
not to like it and democrats are about
to find that out good and hard in 2022.
all right we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content in
the meantime go check out the michael
knowles show that is available right now
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pawel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barbour
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
an austrian brothel offers free sex in
exchange for taking the covid vaccine
the white house tells businesses to
ignore an appeals court stay on the
vaccine mandate and california governor
gavin newsom reappears after a
mysterious absence check it out on the
michael knowles show